bon c'est la cata Henri le castor a
recouvert la jungle d'une substance rose
super dangereuse qui explose au contact
de l'eau
et c'est bientôt la saison des pluies
toute la jungle le risque d'être rasé
pour sauver la jungle les as vont partir
autour du monde pas de temps à perdre on
y va il faut aller par la
ça fait une truc quand même j'ai soif
l'eau est peut-être empoisonnée il faut
pas avoir une sale goutte
pour mener à bien à votre mission vous
allez devoir vous rendre dans l'un des
pires endroits de la planète comment ça
un des pires endroits
[Musique]
Arthur ça fait une heure qu'on attend
vous trouvez pas qu'ils ont l'air d'être
un peu à cran dans le coin
les as de la jungle sont de retour avec
toujours plus de kung-fu je te prends
quand tu veux au concours panda
[Musique]
toujours plus de bananes
et voilà des bananes congelées pour le
moment je peux pas faire mieux que ça
et toujours plus de feuilles
chaque plan a ses embus
[Applaudissements]
les as de la jungle les as de la jungle
2 opération tour du monde
[Musique]